it hasn't been a comfortable week for
department of homeland security
secretary Kristen Nielsen her safe
spaces have been impinged upon by
protesters most multiple times now and
last week I told you that she left the
Mexican restaurant in DC when protesters
picketed her inside the restaurant and
chanted shame and a bunch of other stuff
over her rolled in the child internment
crisis the latest is that protesters
showed up at her house and blasted Audio
of crying immigrant children chanting no
sleep and free the kids we have a little
bit of audio and video for you listen I
wish this weren't necessary but this is
nonviolent protests like I said
yesterday about the request for sarah
huckabee sanders to leave a restaurant
because of her political beliefs
protesting in this way can have
consequences but it is nonviolent speech
period and we have an administration
right now that goes beyond just the
stain for the basic institutions of
american society we've got an
authoritarian White House with total
disregard for the rule of law disregard
for the Constitution when it doesn't
suit this suit them disregard for press
freedom and they lack all empathy in
their policy and the carrying out of
policy we have to scale up I'm not
saying violence I am saying the
desperate times call for desperate
measures and making people uncomfortable
is okay Kristen Nielsen Sarah Huckabee
Sanders Steven Miller they've all had
these bad moments at restaurants in the
last week good it should be
uncomfortable for these people to show
their faces in public send them to
chick-fil-a if they want a safe space at
a restaurant I guess but use speech to
make your political voice heard what
they want is to be depraved
authoritarian ideologues from 9:00 to
5:00 and then to go home or out to eat
and have a quiet
miel well they might have to deal with
protesters and in the meantime keep up
the phone calls
keep up the emails keep up the snail
mail letters and the faxes use fax zero
comm if you want to send fax after fax
after facts to our elected officials I
am reminded of when Michelle Obama said
when they go low we go high and I
believe in that principle when you're
dealing with certain types of people
this is just not one of those times Pat
and I know you didn't love what was done
to Sarah Huckabee Sanders you mentioned
yesterday on the show and some people
wrote in saying they agree more with you
than with me if you let a cheater cheat
they win period and if I'm wrong and I
should be discouraging these protests
tell me why but I believe that these
people must be made uncomfortable I'm
not saying violence but I am saying make
them uncomfortable with your legal right
to free speech I do question whether
kicking out cabinet members from
establishments is crossing the line or
going to these secretaries houses is
crossing the line and I'm struggling
with it a little bit I think you can
make a cogent argument either way it's
it's a tough thing for me anyway I know
I think it just becomes tribal - right
like what if people under the Obama
administration were doing the exact same
thing you know Obama said I could keep
my doctor if I like my doctor and he
kicked me off my health insurance and
now I'm going to protest go to these
cabinet members families you know houses
and all that I think that it gets really
tricky the the right is often using I
think Pat might be listening to a little
too much Sean Hannity radio the right
has been using that hey but Obama lied
about if you want to keep your doctor
you can keep your doctor if you like
your doctor you can keep your doctor I
have no reason to believe that that was
actually a lie like sometimes
politicians say things and I'm not
saying Obama never lied believe me I've
been very critical of Obama if you like
your doctor you can keep your doctor
it didn't work out that way for everyone
but that doesn't mean that it was an
actual lie in the way that the Trump
administration straight-up lies it's not
the matter of lying so much as it is
disagreements and to what point those
disagreements come to where we you have
to act upon them in a way that's not
violent absolutely but flirts worth that
line that you know maybe we shouldn't go
to these people's houses because their
families live there or maybe we
shouldn't kick them out of a stab
because it feels a little bit
reminiscent of the Jim Crow era and it
doesn't feel like it's in line with our
values it's a tough thing let's open it
to the audience
send me your thoughts tell me not so
much who you agree with but what
principle you think is the principle
that is most important in deciding
whether we should support or oppose
these types of protests that have been
taking place over the last 10 days or so